[Musique]
fermez vos yeux 10 secondes et essayez
de vous rappeler ce qui vous rattache à
votre enfance une odeur un bruit une
présence
moi c'est l'odeur de la terre
des fleurs des plantes d'effroi de
l'humus pendant les longues balades dans
la forêt et dans les champs avec mon
père je suis pas pellard lettre au maire
et je suis l'aînée de cinq filles ma
famille était d'origine paysanne et mon
père avait quitté la terre pour devenir
garagiste ma mère pour les des deux
nèthes une station essence
pourtant l'amour de la terre n'avait
jamais quitté mon père il m'a tant
appris pendant six longues balades
ramasser les champignons du pissenlit ou
encore aller pêcher
j'ai grandi scolarité lisse sans relief
pour finalement m'orienter vers l'école
d'éducateurs
j'ai travaillé pendant sept ans dans un
foyer qui accueillait dès jeudi en
grande difficulté à la même époque je
faisais régulièrement du bénévolat dans
une toute petite épicerie de bio de
sélestat et j ai découvert de nombreux
aliments dont je ne soupçonnais même pas
l'existence des algues des céréales
complètes ou encore des produits
macrobiotique je me souviens bien il
s'est collé plus d'une fois en france
mes casseroles l'indispensable et
irremplaçable riz complet
j'aimais beaucoup mon travail
d'éducatrice je prenais beaucoup de
plaisir à accompagner ces jeunes filles
mais au fond de moi je savais que ce
travail je ne le ferai pas toute ma vie
qu'il fallait que je trouve autre chose
au bout de sept ans je décide de prendre
une année dispo pour aller voyager et
découvrir le monde
les cinq premiers mois je pars en grèce
sans stop je dormais le plus souvent sur
la plage j'adorais cette époque vivre
libres aller au gré de mes envies
à mon retour en france des copains me
propose de les accompagner pour aller
découvrir l'afrique en voiture je n'ai
pas hésité une seconde
j'ai acheté une vieille 404 break et me
voilà repartie pour sillonner les dix
pistes du désert et partir à la
découverte de l'afrique noire
ce périple a duré six mois j
les paysages traversés des paysages
grandioses j'ai fait de très belles
rencontres
j'ai vu aussi la pauvreté
sa simplicité des cubains poids des
titres des situations pas simples
des fois risquée et au fond de moi je
savais toujours pas ce que j'allais
faire à mon retour en france
régulièrement il avait une petite loi
qui lui chuchoter à l'oreille mais je ne
la comprenait pas la seule chose que je
savais c'est que j'ai mes voyages et
voir de nouveaux horizons faire de
nouvelles rencontres découvrir le monde
j'avais attrapé le virus du voyage du
retour en france il fallait bien
travailler pour vivre pendant trois ans
j'ai fait des petits boulots vendeuses
sur les premiers salons bio serveuse
dans un petit resto à côté de la
cathédrale et à cette époque le touriste
était généreux donc travaillé quelques
petits mois pour aller voyager ça allait
super bien
la troisième année je suis enceinte
et alors là je me vois encore avec mon
petit ventre bien rond la caisse sous
mon tablier de serveuse à courir de
table en table et je me disais
régulièrement
arlette non je n'ai pas possible tu va
accoucher et on en prendra d'être avec
des billets de banque dans les yeux
presque rats prêt à rendre la monnaie
après la naissance de ma fille j'ai
encore travailler prendre en deux ans à
mi temps dans un petit resto bio café
théâtre
et puis j'ai décidé d'investir toutes
mes économies
avec un copain pour ouvrir une petite
librairie pour enfants et de bandes
dessinées belle et courte aventure
mais fiascos financiers immenses je me
retrouver là avec mon bébé dans une
situation financière moyenne pour ne pas
dire catastrophiques
alors là ma perspective j'en avais fait
pas vraiment c'est dans ces situations
extrêmement que je me disais régulier
régulièrement
arlette eacu de toi j'ai décidé de
revenir à mes premiers amours à ce que
j'aime les plantes la bio les tisanes le
thé c'est aussi à cette époque qu'on
m'avait offert mon premier thé du
darjeeling
c'était du jardin single c'était une
révélation
j'en ai encore le goût dans la bouche à
cette époque je faisais toujours encore
les salons bio pour vivre et c'est sur
l'un de ces salons bio professionnels
que j'ai rencontré un producteur du thé
darjeeling en inde est un producteur de
thé de ceylan cette belle et courte et
ses belles rencontres a essayé décisif
pour moi car c'était le début d'une
belle aventure
au tai ji connaissait pas grand chose et
pourtant j'avais vraiment l'impression
que j'étais enfin à ma place au tj
connaissait pas grand chose ni à
l'entreprise d'ailleurs et à cette
époque les bio c'était considéré comme
des farfelus ou des allumés en somme
j'avais tout pour réussir
mais c'est en me rendant sur le terrain
que je me suis que j'ai vu que la tâche
était vraiment immense
tout restait à faire du thé bio il y en
a mais quasiment pas partout où j'allais
c'était différent
les cultures la fabrication le
savoir-faire les couleurs le goût les
terroirs
mais c'était tellement passionnant on
ateliers c'était bon
cuisine c'est sur une petite table en
bois que je faisais mes petits bélanger
que je remplissais des petits sachets
kraft qui remplace grandes branches qui
rompt qui était un tout ma maison
l'entrepôt c'était ma cave puis j'ai
décidé d'aller faire fabriquer d'été qui
n'existait pas en bio excusez-moi des
grands tyrans bio londres j'ai décidé de
réserver d'acheter à crédit à des petits
producteurs qui m'ont fait confiance
les récoltes je ne savais même pas
comment j'allais les payer mais en fait
il prenait les mêmes risques que moi
dans cette aventure
je me souviens vraiment encore je me
suis toujours je me je me demandais
comment ça allait marcher
je crois que c'était peut-être cette
passion du thé de l'amour de la nature
l'énergie que j'y mettais je crois que
c'était tout ça mais c'était aussi mais
il est des tic de payer des prix justes
pour l'été qui n'existait pas et que les
producteurs avaient plaisir à fabriquer
en même temps il fallait bien entendu
trouver des acheteurs des clients des
magasins qui veulent bien revente ct et
qui partagent peut-être la mémétique au
fil des salons bio et des rencontres
le réseau ces candidats s'est agrandie
ce réseau c'est aussi des magasins qui
comprennent ou qui ont compris que de la
culture à la menthe
nous avions avoir les mêmes valeurs nous
devions être soucieux des ans et des
autres nous étions tous internes
interdépendants sans ça ce n'est pas
parce ce n'était pas possible
au fil des années l'entreprise a grandit
doucement pas toujours facilement j'ai
su m'entourer des bonnes personnes
certaines sont encore à mes côtés
aujourd'hui et d'autres sont venues se
rajouter au fil de l'aventuré
j'avais envie de monter cette petite
entreprise de la campagne de rester
connectés avec la terre je me voyais pas
en ville prendre la voiture le matin est
passé une heure dans les bouchons je
voulais être cohérentes avec ce que j'ai
mais avec ce que j'ai ce dont j'avais
envie
plus d'une fois il a fallu prendre des
décisions rapides pour que cette petite
entreprise de thé fonctionne je me
souviens barend un petit producteur de
reuil boss de la coopérative de
wuppertal en afrique du sud
me disais que les conditions n'étaient
pas optimales pour faire la récolte du
thé il n'avait plus de tracteurs il
fallait pas hésité longtemps à réfléchir
trop longtemps il fallait prendre une
décision trouvé de solution nous avons
trouvé un tracteur d'occasion et nous
l'avons acheté une autre fois série
friends une autre petite coopérative eux
n'avaient pas obtenu les prêts bancaires
pour acheter les des terres agricoles
là encore il fallait se décider
rapidement
nous avons commandé et payé un endroit
ibos al avance une autre encore je me
baladais apportons aux darjeeling en
inde et je voyais des femmes qui montent
et descendent et des pentes abruptes sur
plus de 500 m aller chercher de l'eau à
la rivière et veut dire
arrosez les premiers les jeunes buisson
de thé là encore je me disais vous faire
quelque chose la décision a été prise
instantanément j'allais payer finir
c'est une un système d'irrigation
aujourd'hui 7 mars elle est magnifique
et pour nous remercier
ils ont appelé gabarit parce qu'il veut
dire jardin gaillard ce sont tous ces
exemples et bien d'autres encore qui me
motive me nourrissent
et me donnait envie de continuer cette
interdépendance c'est avant tout être
bienveillant et être soucieux les
angevins autres
la perspective
évidemment c'est que le commerce ne sont
pas uniquement régi par l'argent
le bénéfice le profit mais aussi par le
partage l'entr'aide la confiance le
respect ça marche c'est pas l'utopie du
nine baba cool ou d'une soixante
huitarde
c'est possible ça fonctionne et l'été
gaïa qui fêtent cette année leurs 25 ans
en sont une preuve ce commerce
différents est ce que j'appelle un
commerce solidaire et juste
alors demain
dans nos entreprises mais aussi dans nos
vies avant de commencer quelque chose
posons nous la question du pourquoi du
sens et pas seulement du commun pour
finir j'aimerais juste vous dire une
petite citation de pierre rabhi qui m'a
accompagné pendant toute cette aventure
et qui me motive encore la planète terre
est à ce jour la seule oasis de vie que
nous connaissons au sein d'un immense
désert sidéral en prendre soin respecter
son intégrité physique et biologique
tirer parti de ses ressources avec
modération
il ya instauré la paix la solidarité
entre les humains dans le respect de
toutes formes de vie et le plonger le
projet le plus réaliste et le plus
magnifique qui soit merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]